hi herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live
schön dass ihr dabei seid wir gucken
heute auf die aktuelle Lage der
Unterstützung für die Ukraine in immer
mehr Ländern stehen nämlich die
militärischen und die finanziellen
Hilfen so ein bisschen auf der Kippe in
der Slowakei gab es jetzt Wahlen und
dort gewann Putin Sympathisant fizo die
Wahlen und auch die polnische Regierung
rückt jetzt kurz vor einer Wahl im
wahlkamp langsam von selenskis Seite ab
und auch aus den USA könnten weitere
ukrainehilfen wegen eines
Haushaltsstreits vorerst ausbleiben ja
und gleichzeitig gibt es dann diese
Bilder die Außenminister und
Ministerinnen der EU Mitgliedstaaten
trafen sich heute in Kiev und damit zum
ersten Mal außerhalb der EU-Grenzen das
gab es so noch nie auch die deutsche
Außenministerin andalena berbock ist
nach Kiev gereist und hat dort erneut
einen winterschutzschirm und eine
zukünftige Aufnahme der Ukraine in die
die EU
gefordert ja ziemlich starke ziemlich
symbolträchtige Bilder also aus K kiefev
aber wie steht es denn abseits dieser
Bilder um die aktuelle Unterstützung der
Ukraine innerhalb der EU auch von Seiten
der USA und inwiefern profitiert Putin
von diesen aktuellen Entwicklungen dasu
wollen wir heute bei ZDF heute live
diskutieren und wie immer tu ich das
nicht alleine sondern mit Gästen wir
sprechen mit ZDF Korrespondent Ulf
Röller der uns aus Brüssel zugeschaltet
ist und mit Militärexperte Oberst ad
Wolfgang Richter und wie immer
diskutieren wir auch mit euch wenn ihr
Fragen zum Thema habt oder eure Meinung
mit uns teilen wollt dann schreibt uns
wie immer einfach hier im Youtube ch
Chat oder an die Mailadresse die ihr da
gerade eingeblendet seht jetzt schalten
wir aber erstmal zu unserem
Militärexperten zu oberst ad Wolfgang
Richter guten Abend Herr Richter schönen
guten Abend Frau Reich Herr Richter wir
haben gerade diese Bilder gesehen das
sieht wichtig aus das sendet starke
Signale was was bringt dieses Treffen in
Kiev aber abseits dieser
symbolträchtigen
Bilder also es ist schon richtig was sie
sagten es ist vor allenen symbolträchtig
weil es sehr deutlich geworden ist dass
es erste Risse in der EU gibt und das
hat ja der litauische Außenminister auch
deutlich ausgedrückt und es gilt jetzt
diesen Rissen oder dem Eindruck dass die
Unterstützung bröckelt entgegenzutreten
sie bröckelt tatsächlich in zwei drei
Staaten das ist in Polen durch die
Äußerung des Premierministers
möglicherweise jetzt in der Kai Ungarn
war ja schon immer etwas Abseits
gestanden aber die EU hat natürlich
viele andere Staaten äh und ich glaube
da wird die Unterstützung auch
weitergehen zum WE sich die EU
verpflichtet hat beispielsweise Munition
herzustellen eine Million Granaten
innerhalb eines Jahres für sehr viel
Geld äh und das wird auch weitergehen
genauso wie die Ausbildung an F16
Kampfflugzeugen die in Dänemark
angelaufen istind in rumenien äh ich
glaube dass für dieses Jahr die
Unterstützung Z nächst ein mal so
weiterläuft wie sie vereinbart wurde
aber es sind natürlich schlechte Zeichen
für die Zukunft und für einen langen
Krieg ja und da sind wir auch direkt
beim Faktor Zeit der ist für diesen
Krieg ja sehr bedeutend Herr Richter
vielen Dank bis hierhin wir sprechen uns
gleich noch mal zu den militärischen
folgen so einer Unterstützung oder einer
ausbleibenden Unterstützung bis
gleich ja und jetzt gucken wir noch mal
auf Zahlen und Fakten zu diesem Thema
dieser Krieg geht ja Hal schon ganz
schön lange und wir wollen euch noch mal
in Erinnerung rufen welches Land liefert
eigentlich was welches Land unterstützt
die Ukraine wie stark und in welchem
Umfang und das hat sich mein Kollege
Jonas Kapp für uns
angeschaut die Ukraine empfängt Hilfe
aus vielen einzelnen verschiedenen
Ländern allen voran den USA seit
Kriegsbeginn haben sie der Ukraine
Unterstützung in Höhe von rund 69,5
Milliarden Euro zugesichert einst
international als Bremser kritisiert ist
Deutschland heute mit knapp 21
Milliarden Euro das zweitgrößte
unterstützerland der Ukraine
darauf folgt Großbritannien mit rund
13,8 Milliarden Euro an Platz 7 ist
Polen mit rund 4,3 Milliarden Euro die
Summen setzen sich zusammen aus
finanziellen humanitären und
militärischen Leistungen Waffen und
Ausrüstung machen den Großteil der
deutschen Hilfe aus andere Länder geben
der Ukraine vor allem Geld die größte
Unterstützung aber kommt aus Europa
selbst mit verschiedenen Maßnahmen steht
die EU an der Seite der Ukraine
insgesamt mit einem Volumen von knapp 85
Milliarden Euro wanken nun Länder wie
die Slowakei und Polen könnte sich das
auf die gesamteuropäische Hilfe für die
Ukraine
auswirken ja und über diese möglichen
Auswirkungen spreche ich jetzt mit
Korrespondent Ulf Röller der uns live
aus Brüssel zugeschaltet ist da ist er
schon hallo Ulf hallo Ulf du warst für
das ZDF bereits in China du warst
bereits in den USA und kannst deswegen
jetzt ganz gut mit uns diese
Geschehnisse einordnen auch noch mal die
Frage an dich was bedeutet dieses
Treffen in Kiev heute und wie viel ist
dabei jetzt wirklich
rausgekommen also ich glaube die
Symbolik hat wirklich eine historische
Bedeutung es ist das erste Mal dass der
EU Außenminister außerhalb der EU
wirklich sich treffen und dann in einem
Kriegsgebiet das verlangt auch Mut das
muss man anerkennen und das ist ein
wichtiges Zeichen nach Moskau allerdings
auf der zweiten Ebene wenn man ein
bisschen den klämer wegschiebt muss man
sagen so richtig konkretes ist nicht
rausgekommen es gibt keine dauerhafte
stabile Finanzierung der Ukraine das ist
bisher immer noch nicht gelungen vor
allem Länder wie Ungarn speren sich
dagegen und auch bei der anderen Frage
der EU Erweiterung die Ukraine will ja
in die EU gibt es keine konkreten
Zusagen eher da auch nur mehr die
Symbolik ihr gehört zu Europa aber wenn
es konkret wird und wenn man dann mit
Regierungschefs spricht hinter
vorgehalten Hand sagen viele das kann
auch sehr sehr lange dauern bis die
Ukraine irgendwie in Europa ankommt also
die Bilder sind großartig aber man merkt
doch eine größer wachsende Unsicherheit
umso länger der Krieg
geht ja und diese Bilder sollen uns
natürlich auch Einigkeit vermitteln
jetzt gab es ja da aber einen wichtigen
Punkt nämlich waren die Außenminister
von Polen und Ungarn heute in Kiev nicht
dabei was sagt uns das denn über die
Einheit innerhalb der
EU also ich glaube das ist eben auch
eine große Symbolik dass beide nicht
dabei waren oder besser gesagt sie waren
nicht auf Ministerebene dabei man hat
ein klares Zeichen gesetzt man ist
wesentlich skeptischer was diesen
ukraineansatz angeht dieser Widerstand
gegen teilweise die ukraineepolitik
offizielle der EU der ist sehr deutlich
von Polen und Ungarn der wird auch
deutlich offiziell gemacht weil das der
Stimmung zu Hause in Polen und Ungarn
gut tut das hilft den Politikern aber
auch wie gesagt hinter vorgehalten Hand
gibt es doch auch mehr Skepsis weil
viele sagen dieser Krieg dauert sehr
lange was ist das
Ausstiegsszenario das wissen wir nicht
und halten wir das wirklich dort durch
und der ganz wichtige Punkt den man
glaube ich nicht vor Europa
unterschätzen darf ist die Entwicklung
in Amerika wir wissen ja gerade der
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz hat immer
wieder gesagt er richtet seine ganze
ukraineepitik seine ganzen
Waffenlieferung immer auch nach Amerika
aus und dass dort nun die politische
Stimmung teilweise gibt dass die
ukrainehilfe eben wirklich in Frage
gestellt wird von weiten Teilen der
Republikaner und auch der Bevölkerung
das sind doch bedrohliche Zeichen weil
wenn Amerika nicht mehr an der Seite der
Ukraine steckt steht oder wackelt dann
wird es für Europa sehr schwer diesen
Kurs der Loyalität und Solidarität mit
mit der Ukraine
durchzuhalten ja und du sagst es schon
die USA stehen ja auch am Platz 1 der
Unterstützer was so Volumen angeht
sowohl an militärischen Gerät als auch
an finanziellen Hilfen und da gibt es
ein politisches Umdenken das gibt es ja
aber auch in der Slowakei wo gerade ein
Putin Sympathisant die Wahlen gewonnen
hat äh und auch in Polen ist Wahlkampf
man merkt da steht eine
richtungsweisende Wahl an da wird auch
rhetorisch die Unterstützung der Ukraine
so ein Stück schwächer woher kommt denn
in diesem Teil dieses
Umdenken also ich glaube das ist so ein
bisschen was wir auch in Amerika gehabt
haben und beide Länder sind ja sehr auf
Amerika fixiert und teilweise auch auf
Donald Trump fixiert das ist dieses
America first oder jetzt Polen first
oder die Slowakei first der polnisch reg
Chef hat ja sehr deutlich gesagt wir
können nicht mehr weiter Waffen liefern
so wie wir wollen wir müssen an unsere
eigene nationale Sicherheit denken wir
dürfen nicht riskieren dass wir die
Waffen der Ukraine liefern und die uns
dann fehlen ich glaube der polnische
Präsident hat sogar gesagt man muss
aufpassen dass man sich nicht an einen
Ertrinkenden hängt und er hat damit die
Ukraine gemerkt weil man damit selber
untergeht das sind Töne die kommen in
Polen teilweise gut an weil man dann
sehr deut ich macht bei den
Konservativen wir denken zuerst an Polen
und eben nicht an die Ukraine aber darin
sieht man eben auch die Gefahr dass
diese nationalen oder nationalistischen
Strömung eben Strömungen sind die nicht
mehr so massiv die Ukraine unterstützen
wie das vorher der Fall war und dazu
haben wir auch direkt eine Frage aus der
Community an Dich hier fragt jemand auf
Youtube erwarten sie denn dass in den
nächsten Monaten ein EU-Staat die
Sanktionen gegenüber Russland aufheben
wird
also das ist schwer zu sagen ähm
zumindestens hat ja der ungarische
Regierungschef Orban jetzt verhindert
dass weitere sanktionsverschärfungen
stattfinden und deshalb bin ich mir
nicht sicher ob er das wie weit er das
Spiel treibt oder wie weit er das ernst
meint bisher sehe ich das noch nicht
aber man muss auch bei den Sanktionen
sagen und das spielt auch eine Rolle bei
der Beurteilung der Unterstützung der
Ukraine die Sanktionen gegen Russland
sind ja wesentlich weniger erfolgreich
geworden als sich das Europa wirklich
erhofft hat die Rüstungsindustrie der
der Russen funktioniert nach wie vor
sehr sehr gut sie ist nicht
zusammengebrochen das
Wirtschaftswachstum der Russen ist in
diesem Jahr oder im nächsten Jahr
vorhergesehen
1,3% plus das deutsche
Wirtschaftswachstum soll nächstes Jahr -
0,6 sein also man sieht die die
russische Wirtschaft ist zwar
angeschlagen aber im Vergleich auch zu
anderen Ländern weiß Gott haben die
Sanktionen nicht den Effekt gehabt den
man sich gewünscht hat das führt auch
dazu dass natürlich diese harte Politik
gegen die Ukraine und diese
Sanktionspolitik die ja auch eine
Auswirkung hat auf Europa wenn wir uns
an die Energie denken wenn wir uns an
die Gaslieferung Denken von Russland
dass diese Politik natürlich ein
bisschen Frage gestellt wird weil sie
nicht wirklich Russland so hart trifft
wie man das will und teilweise Europa
sehr hart trifft mhm wir haben hier
gleich noch eine nächste Frage an dich
äh und zwar fragt icke auf YouTube in
wie weit würden Sie sagen dass die
ukrainische Korruption bisher die
gesamte finanzielle Unterstützung
beeinträchtigt hat das ist ja auch ein
Thema was jetzt viel mehr besprochen
wird als noch vor ein paar
Monaten also es wird ja am Ende des
Jahres wird die Europäische Kommission
ein Bericht vorlegen wie weit die
Ukraine gekommen ist in der Bekämpfung
der Korruption das ist ganz wichtig für
die Frage nimmt man ähm
erweiterungsgespräche mit der Ukraine
auf oder nicht ich glaube dass die
diese Korruption der Ukraine spätestens
seit sie ihren Verteidigungsministern es
waren glaube ich sechs Stellvertreter
oder sechs Menschen aus dem
militärischen Komplex entlassen mussten
wegen Korruption ist doch deutlich
geworden dass die Ukraine eben noch
keine ich verwende mal ein bisschen
toxischen Begriff keine lupenreine
Demokratie ist das spielt eine
zunehmende Rolle natürlich wird immer
wieder gesagt und das auch nicht nur
hinter vorgehaltene Hand von fast allen
Regierungschefs dass sich selenski
massiv
bemüht und auch Erfolge erzielt hat in
der Bekämpfung der Korruption ob das
reicht dass am Ende wirklich
Beitrittsgespräche stattfinden das wird
man Ende des Jahres sehen aber das Thema
Korruption ist ein bisschen weiter ein
Thema das die EU sehr beschäftigt aber
wie gesagt sie spricht darüber nicht
ganz so laut weil das ein Thema ist auf
die man noch keine hundertprozentige
Antwort
hat ja ich fasse noch mal zusammen wir
sehen in dieser breiten Unterstützung
der Ukraine der letzten ja jetzt schon
anderthalb Jahre erste Risse es scheint
ein Umdenken anstellen zu geben da wird
gesagt America first Polen first und wir
fragen uns natürlich auch inwiefern nüzt
diese Tendenz die wir da gerade sehen
auch
Putin also ich glaube sie nutzt Putin
und sie nutzt dem eigentlich wichtigsten
Player über den wir noch nicht
gesprochen haben über die Chinesen die
ja doch weiter loyal an der russischen
Seite stehen an Putins Seite stehen den
zu Beginn des Krieges hatte man gehofft
seitens der Europäer und auch der
Amerikaner dass die Chinesen sich
vielleicht von den Russen lossagen
würden aber das Gegenteil ist der Fall
und beide Putin und der chinesische
Präsident chiiing die haben eigentlich
das Gefühl glaube ich dass dieser Krieg
doch ein bisschen nach einem Drehbuch
abläuft wie sie das erhoffen sich
zumindestens nämlich dass die
Demokratien müde werden dieses Krieges
dass es dann innerhalb der Demokratien
Streit gibt dass vor allem in Amerika
die Polarisierung zwischen Trump und
beiden dieses Land so lahm legt und dass
die Diskussion um die ob man die Ukraine
unterstützt od nicht so das Land spaltet
dass es geschwächt ist und dass das
eigentlich aufgeht dass am Ende
Demokratien eben nicht stark genug sind
diesem Angriff der Diktaturen
standzuhalten ob das aufgeht keiner weiß
das aber das ist ein bisschen die Idee
dahinter die Putin und shichiping haben
Ulf vielen Dank für deine Analyse und
deine Antworten auf unsere Fragen
schönen Abend noch und alles Gute nach
Brüssel vielen Dank alles Gute euch
auch ja und von dieser politischen
Dimension oder von der politischen
Perspektive auf dieses Thema kommen wir
jetzt noch mal auf die militärische
Perspektive und wir fragen uns was
bedeutet das eigentlich alles ganz
konkret für den Kriegsverlauf und das
tun wir noch mal gemeinsam mit Oberst ad
Wolfgang richichter schönen guten abend
noch mal schönen guten Abend noch fr
auch an sie noch mal die Frage wir haben
die Tendenz in der Slowakei dass da ein
Kandidat gewinnt der sagt die Slowaken
die haben größere Probleme als das Thema
Ukraine die Slowakei hat aber bisher die
Ukraine eigentlich sehr stark
unterstützt da wurde z.B auch ein
luftwehr ABS Luftabwehrsystem geliefert
und wir fragen jetzt mal wirklich auf
der Faktenlage basieren wie stark würde
denn theoretisch ein Ende dieser
militärischen Unterstützung aus der
Slowakei die Ukraine wirklich
treffen also die Slowaken haben in der
Tat schon einiges geliefert unter
anderem auch im im Ringtausch mit
Deutschland sie haben Luftabwehrsysteme
äh Panzer panzerhbitzen Schützenpanzer
und t72 Kampfpanzer geliefert alle
sowjetischen Designs oder
Nachfolgemodelle die dann in der Ukraine
auch gut integriert werden konnten weil
die Ukraine ja ähnliches Material fahren
die Slowaken sind aber nicht in der Lage
jetzt
in diesem Umfang weiterzuliefern denn
diese Lieferung die haben ja schon im
letzten Winter stattgefunden äh das
heißt es wird sich kurzfristig erstmal
überhaupt nicht auswirken den den ich äh
denn die äh Verpflichtungen die die EU
übernommen hat aber auch die
randsteingruppe insgesamt es
überschneidet sich ja äh bleiben ja
zunächst einmal bestehen und selbst der
polnische Ministerpräsident morwietki
hat auch gesagt dass seine Äußerung
nicht so zu verstehen ist dass die
Verpflichtung die Polen eingegangen ist
nicht mehr eingehalten werden also das
was schon vereinbart wird wurde wird
geliefert in diesem Jahr sehe ich keine
gravierenden Auswirkungen es wird
sicherlich in der EU noch heftige Kämpfe
geben ob man äh die äh 5 Milliarden die
Z nächst mal angepeilt sind pro Jahr
verstätigen kann trotzdem äh werden
natürlich die begonnenen
ausrüstungshilfen die Zusagen
eingehalten ich sehe vorläufig keine äh
konkrete Auswirkung allerdings
langfristig mag das völlig anders
ausschauen und hier werden wir natürlich
auch nicht nur auf das Material gucken
müssen sondern auch auf die
Personalreserven der Ukraine äh die
wirklich zur Neige gehen und wo es einen
hohen demografischen Verlust auch gibt
das scheint nicht so zu sein dass ein
langwieriger Krieg dann wirklich im
Interesse der Ukraine ist und Ulf rer
hat das angesprochen aussliegsszenarien
sind derzeit nicht zu sehen aber sie
müssen angedacht werden mhm jetzt haben
sie gerade schon gesagt was erstmal
versprochen wurde wird auch geliefert
dieses Jahr wird sich noch gar nicht so
viel verändern jetzt erleben wir aber
auch diese Tendenz oder zumindest
zumindest die Gespräche um eine
Verminderung der Unterstützung
langfristig damit auch eine politische
Orientierung die erleben wir auch in
Polen jetzt vor dieser Wahl was würde
denn perspektivisch passieren wenn Polen
sagen wir mal ab nächstem Jahr dann
nicht mehr das liefern würde was sie
bisher
liefern also Polen nimmt hier eine
Sonderrolle wahr denn sie haben in der
Tat sehr sehr viel geliefert an die
Ukraine vor allen Dingen fast ihren
ganzen panzerbestand sowjetischer
Herkunft schitzenpanzer und Artillerie
etc da waren sie mit die
Hauptlieferanten was sowjetisches Design
betrifft jetzt aber will Polen ja sie
selbst sagen die stärkste Militärmacht
Europas werden das heißt sie kaufen sehr
viel ein in den USA und vor allen Dingen
auch in Südkorea und wollen also eine
panzerarmee von rund 1000 Kampfpanzern
und entsprechend vielen anderen Geräten
aufbauen dafür brauchen sie viel Geld
und das mag auch dahinterstehen dass sie
jetzt sagen wir wollen uns erstmal um
unsere eigene Verteidigung kümmern denn
möglicherweise äh wird das alles
versanden was wir in die Ukraine
schicken und
natürlich dahinter stehen auch Zweifel
an den militärischen Erfolgen Zweifel
die die wir allerdings auch aus
Washington gehört haben ich sehe
allerdings nicht dass diese Zweifel in
dieser Form etwa in Deutschland
Frankreich oder Großbritannien
wiederholt werden und das sind ja auch
wichtige Geberländer
dort sehe ich noch kein
bröckeln da noch kein bröckeln aber bei
dem größten Zulieferer beim größten
Unterstützer da erleben wir aktuell auch
eine Debatte darüber wie stark die
Ukraine unterstützt werden soll gerade
auch perspektivisch im nächsten Jahr
2000 24 da ist nämlich auch Wahljahr in
den USA wie wichtig ist in dieser
Zeitfaktor für eine weitere
Unterstützung aus den USA und ja wie
könnte dieser Wahlkampf das Thema für
sich nutzen ja zunächst einmal wird es
wahrscheinlich Einschränkungen schon im
wallkampf geben weil beiden muss
natürlich auch auf die Wählerschaft
Rücksicht nehmen und wie ja schon
erklärt worden ist sind die Hilfen an
die Ukraine nicht unbedingt mehr so
populär wie sie mal waren das heißt der
wird auch auf diese Wählerschaft schauen
und wird versuchen Republik also Wähler
die jetzt eher für die Republikaner
Stimmen für sich zu gewinnen und das
bedeutet auch dass er die ukrainehilfe
dann niedriger hängen muss das ist genau
die Gefahr die selenski ja auch gesehen
hat äh und in der Tat wenn die wenn die
USA ausfallen sollte dann ist das ein
heftiger Einschnitt äh denn äh sie äh
tragen ja ungefähr zwei Drittel der
gesamten Ausbildungshilfe
ausrüstungshilfe für die Ukraine
allerdings muss man sagen dass so
eindeutig die Meinung bei den republikan
auch nicht äh ist sondern es gibt
natürlich sehr viele
konservative Republikaner die durchaus
an diesen Hilfen festhalten trotzdem
weiß man um die Risiken des Pol des
Wahlkampfes und das wird man einbauen
müssen in eine Strategie oder in ein
Ausstiegsszenario denn
eine langfristige ein langfristiger
Krieg der Z lastasten des ukrainischen
Personals geht und der am Ende
möglicherweise dann was die materielle
Unterstützung betrifft bröckelt ist
nicht im Interesse KIS und ist auch
nicht im Interesse Europas das heißt he
wir brauchen hier ein anderes Szenario
und müssen überlegen wie wir einerseits
die Hilfe durchhalten andererseits aber
auch versuchen diesen Krieg zu been und
da schließe ich direkt eine Frage aus
unserer Community an die auf dem aufbaut
was wir gerade besprochen haben und zwar
fragt Rom auf Youtube kann die Ukraine
es denn schaffen durch hochfahren
eigener Produktion von Waffen und
Innovation den Ausfall westlicher Waffen
zu
kompensieren ich glaube dass dieser Zug
etwas abgefahren ist also Präsident
selenski hat das zwar jetzt so
äh entschieden dass die ukrainische
Rüstungsproduktion wieder hochgefahren
wird man darf nicht vergessen das war
eine sehr starke Rüstungsindustrie ein
Drittel der gesamten sowjetischen
Rüstungsindustrie war auf ukrainischenem
Boden äh die Ukraine war mal
viertgrößter rüstungsexporteur vor 2014
äh das ist natürlich mittlerweile
eingeschränkt worden durch den Krieg
selbst durch Gebietsverluste aber auch
durch Angriffe auf die
energieinrastruktur
äh selenski B das wieder hoch fahren
weil er sieht dass es möglicherweise
langfristig schwierig wird äh auf der
anderen Seite ist die Ukraine gerade
durch die vielen westlichen
Waffenlieferungen mehr und mehr in
Abhängigkeit geraten von der westlichen
Logistik also es sind ja Geschütze mit
und auch panzerkanonen mit völlig
anderen Kalibern die dort ja nicht
hergestellt werden die Munition muss
also aus dem Westen kommen und genau
darum geht es auch die EU hat sicher
verpflichtet entsprechend
Artilleriegranaten äh in Millionenhöhe
dann herzustellen aber auch die
einzelnen Staaten der ramsteingruppe äh
tun dies und äh es ist auch hier
natürlich eine gewisse Gefahr dass man
mit dieser Abhängigkeit damit auch von
den politischen Risiken im Westen mehr
abhängig wird und ich glaube nicht dass
die Ukraine jetzt in der Lage ist das
rudter hier völlig
rumzurassen und davon geht auch ein User
aus der gleich die nächste Frage stellt
äh auf Youtube fragt er wenn die
Unterstützung aus dem Westen ausbleibt
dann wird es wohl nur eine Frage der
Zeit sein wann die Ukraine fällt ist es
nicht genau das worauf Russland immer
spekuliert hat und dabei sind wir damit
sind wir auch schon bei der russischen
Perspektive auf diese aktuellen
Geschehnisse also ich glaube schon dass
man im Kremel versucht so lange
durchzuhalten wie man dort glaubt dass
der Westen dann eben noch in der Lage
ist zu liefern aber dann wird es eben
bröckeln und die ersten Anzeichen sehen
wir jetzt ich persönlich glaube das noch
nicht so ich glaube der schlüssselfaktor
werden tatsächlich die USA sein ich habe
überhaupt keine Zweifel dass
Großbritannien Frankreich Deutschland
Italien und andere Spanien und andere
europäische stand Nachbarstaaten diese
Unterstützung durchhalten werden ein
einen völligen Ausfall der USA sehe ich
im Moment noch nicht natürlich ist das
Risiko hoch das kann man jetzt noch
nicht vorher sagen aber es muss
eingebaut werden in die eigene Strategie
denn es gibt äh natürlich auch keine
großen militärischen Erfolge Russland so
wenig wie Ukraine in der Lage war jetzt
die kriegswände herbeizuführen auch
nicht westlichen Gerät sod dass ich eine
patsituation sehe einen abnutzungskrieg
sehe der zu Lasten beider Seiten geht
und es wird möglicherweise eine
Situation kommen wo auch beide Seiten
das tun müssen was sie schon einmal zu
Kriegsbeginn gemacht haben nämlich zu
versuchen über Verhandlungen einen
Kompromiss zu
erziehen mhm sie sprechen jetzt gerade
schon von diesem abnutzungskrieg also
ein Krieg der sich über eine sehr lange
Zeit erstreckt und beiden Seiten
wertvolle Ressourcen raubt und ähm das
ist auch eigentlich meine nächste Frage
dieser Zeitfaktor was für eine Bedeutung
hat der für
Putin also er hat sicherlich
eineings muss man dazu sagen dass auch
Putin Probleme hat
mit dem Personal er hat er kann zwar auf
eine ganz andere demographische
Grundlage zurückgreifen also die
altersgehorten der Jahrgänge zwischen 19
und 30 Jahren sind natürlich viermal so
groß wie die der Ukrain und da kann man
noch viele Reserven generieren aber
diese dieses herausziehen von Reserven
aus der Bevölkerung ist natürlich völlig
unpopulär und es
heißt natürlich oder es bedeutet auch
dass die das narrativ nicht mehr
zutrifft dass man eine
spezialmilitäroperation durchführt die
die Zivilbevölkerung in Russland gar
nicht betrifft sondern das sei so eine
Sache für die Profis das narrativ wird
ja schon durch die Mobilisierung des
letzten Jahres im September eigentlich
kritisiert oder Lügen gestraft und wenn
das noch einmal eine solche wellle gibt
weiß man natürlich nicht wie die
innenpolitische Reaktion ist vor allen
Dingen aber die Reaktion der Eliten wir
haben ja in einemfall schon gesehen dass
es ein Militärführer gab also briosin
der Führer der wagnergruppe der so eine
kurzfristige militärrebellion versucht
hat wie viel Sympathisanten er hatte
können wir nicht sagen keiner weiß wie
stabil also dieses Regime ist das heißt
eine weitere Mobilisierung die
demographisch möglich ist ist mit hohen
politischen Risiken verbunden es könnte
auch im Interesse Russlands sein dieses
Spiel irgendwann zu beenden allerdings
möglicherweise zu einem Preis den im
Moment KEV nicht bezahlen will mhm hier
fragt noch jemand auf Youtube was
schätzen Sie denn wie lange kann
Russland materielle Ressourcen und
Waffen aufrecht erhalten wie ist es denn
um deren Lagerbestände
bestellt also wenn sie in die Daten des
Instituts für strategische Studien in
London schauen oder auch an andere
Quellen dann sieht man dass Russland
noch sehr viele Kräfte oder
Waffensysteme in Depots hat sind aber
ältere Waffensysteme die möglicherweise
auch nicht gut gewartet sind die Russen
haben alles dran gesetzt das jetzt
wieder instand zu setzen denn auch die
Masse zählt nicht nur die hohe Qualität
im Gefecht der verbundenen Waffen und
das heißt sie haben schon noch eine
ganze Reihe von Ressourcen und Ulf Rölle
hat es vorhin aus meiner Sicht zurecht
gesagt dass wir im Westen auch ein
bisschen die Sanktionen überschätzt
haben gegenüber Russland und die
Resilienz der russischen
Rüstungsindustrie unterschätzt haben und
vor allen Dingen äh erstaunlicherweise
völlig überrascht davon waren dass der
globale Süden hier nicht mitspielen will
sondern dass er sagt das ist ja euer
Krieg im Norden das der Krieg der
früheren Kolonialmächte wir haben ganz
andere Interessen da reihen wir uns
nicht in eine globale Konfrontation ein
das sind alles die Probleme die man hier
berücksichtigen muss das heißt ich gehe
davon aus dass Russland noch eine ganze
Weile Material nachschieben kann was
kann natürlich auch der Westen rein
ökonomisch könnte er das eigentlich noch
in weitaus größeren Umfang die Frage ist
ob wir in der Lage sind so zu einer Art
Kriegsproduktion umzuschalten ob dazu
der Wille der politische Wille überhaupt
besteht oder ob das nicht auch im besten
dann neue Friktion
vorf ich werfe hier gerade mal so ein
Blick in den Chat und da gibt's noch ein
paar Fragen die auch die Rolle
Deutschlands betreffen hinsichtlich der
Unterstützung der Ukraine hier fragt zum
einen Guardian auf Youtube warum wird
bei Taurus so lange gewartet denken sie
dass das kann denken Sie das kann
technische Gründe haben oder sind es
politische Gründe ja hier verquicken
sich natürlich technische und politische
Gründe wenn sie mal
schauen nicht nur auf das
Reichweitenproblem das ja auch weithin
diskutiert worden ist also mit 500 km
Reichweite wäre das das längste oder das
langstreckensystem mit der größten
reichwete das bisher geliefert worden
ist wenn sie vergleichen die Storm
Shadow der dritten und die GLE das
Gleichartige skalalpsystem der Franzosen
hat ungefähr die Hälfte dieser
Reichweite
die Amerikaner haben bisher keine
Langstreckenwaffen geliefert die 80 km
hinausgehen
und das bedeutet dass Deutschland dann
auch politisch in eine sonderituation
kommt als nicht nukleer macht im
Vergleich zu dem
zu der atomach Russlands das will man
vermeiden das wollte der Kanzler immer
vermeiden schon beim Kampfpanzer bei der
Diskussion um Kampfpanzer hatte Wert
darauf gelegt dass die anderen
Nuklearmächte sich solidarisch zeigen
und das haben sie damals auch getan wenn
auch nur mit einer geringen Zahl an
Kampfpanzern das ist hier ähnlich aber
es geht hier auch um andere Probleme äh
es gibt ein sehr redundantes
Steuerungssystem das zum Teil auf
Satellitensignalen berut also GPS System
das aber auch ein einen
geländerferenzmodus hat wo man also
abgleicht den die Flugstrecke die man
überflogen hat das muss gefüttert werden
mit Daten äh und das ist ein sehr
komplexer Vorgang denn er braucht
natürlich auch Aufklärungsdaten man muss
die Strecke dann entsprechend
äh regulieren und hier für knüpfen sich
dann möglicherweise Fragen der direkten
Beteiligung deutscher Spezialisten in
einen solchen Einsatz das muss man schon
berücksichtigen
äh dazu kommt die Frage der Strategie
der Ukraine also Sie haben ja
versprochen dass sie mit westlichen
Systemen keine Ziele in Russland
angreifen aber es gibt kutzonen dazu
zähle ich natürlich alle Ziele auf der
Krim die ja aus Sicht Moskaus und noch
viele westlicher Staaten völlig legitime
Ziele sind und dann geht es um so
knackpunktziele wie die Brücke bei
Kersch äh die äh eine wesentliche
lebensater für die Krim ist und dann
geht es um die Aussage von beiden dass
die Krim für die für Putin eine rote
Linie darstellt dass er also bereit wäre
sogar zu eskalieren all diese Fragen
müssen bedacht werden da verknüpfen sich
also technische Probleme mit politischen
mhm und hier ist noch mal ein Blick so
ein bisschen in die Historie der
deutschen Unterstützung hier fragt
jemand auf youtube hat Scholz nicht
damals mit seiner fast einjährigen
panzerblockade einen großen und frühen
Erfolg der Ukrainer verspielt Thema
deutsche
Zögerlichkeit also das teile ich nicht
diese Blockade wä ja nicht ein Jahr
sondern die ganze ramsteingruppe die
ganze NATO hat drüber nachgedacht wie
man die Ukrain unterstützen kann es ging
los mit leichten Panzerabwehrwaffen das
kam dann die Diskussion um
artilleriesysteme wo wir relativ schnell
dann auch geliefert haben Deutschland
war eine der drei Nationen neben USA und
Großbritannien die z.B mehrfach
Raketenwerfer geliefert hat die sehr
präzise sind und die eine große
Reichweite ren von 70 km das gilt auch
für die rohrgeschütze die anerze 2000
dies so den besten Systemen dort gehört
also das teile ich dort nicht die
Debatte über Kampfpanzer kam sehr viel
später sie hat sich zunächst mal im
Herbst entzündet letzten Jahres an der
Frage ob man Panzer sowjetischer Bauart
liefert im Ringtausch da waren die Polen
Slowaken Tschechen und Slowenien gefragt
und erst ab Winter oder ab Januar kam
dann diese kampfpanzerdebatte und wie
ich schon vorhin sagt das ist dann eine
Frage auch der politischen Solidarität
gewesen dass die nichtnuklearmacht
Deutschland gesagt hat wir wollen
vermeiden dass der Leopard als Standard
Kampfpanzer vieler europäischer Staaten
sozusagen in Klammern also in
Anführungszeichen als deutscher Panzer
den russischen gegenüber steht und genau
dieses narrativ hat Putin ja auch in
Stalingrad angesichts den äh bulgargrad
wgograd angesichts der Stalingrad
Ereignisse dann wirklich auch geprägt
indem man sagt sagte wiederstehen
deutsche
Leopard Kampfpanzer den russischen
gegenüber
genau diese Punkte sollten vermieden
werden deswegen auch die Frage nach der
Solidarität der Amerikaner und der
brittenen auch der Franzosen und das ist
ja auch geschehen und als wir dann
bereit waren zu liefern stellte sich
heraus dass aber die anderen dann
gezögert haben und nicht bereit waren zu
liefern jedenfalls nicht schnell das
stand W standand mal kurzfristig auch
relativ alleine auf weitem Flur bis sich
diese panzerkoalition dann tatsächlich
gewillet hat
ja lassen Sie uns abschließend noch mal
einen Blick in die Zukunft werfen das
ist ja heute sowieso schon Teil dieses
Streams weil wir sehr weit in die
Zukunft schauen müssen hier fragt noch
jemand auf Youtube wie könnte eine
mögliche exitstategie für Putin aussehen
und gibt es Anzeichen dafür dass
Russland auch solche Optionen in
Betracht
zieht also wir können zunächst mal
zurück zurückblicken auf den 29 März des
letzten Jahres da gab es Verhandlungen
oder das Ergebnis von Verhandlungen die
fast unmittelbar nach dem russischen
Angriff begonnen haben und diese
Verhandlungen sahen mehrere Punkte vor
die von Bedeutung waren erstens die
Ukraine tritt nicht der NATO bei
zweitens
es wird ein weiterer Sonderstatus für
Minsk für für die Ostukraine also den
donbas vereinbart das hörte sich sehr
nach einem weiteren minskabkommen an
drittens es gibt eine de facto
Anerkennung vorläufig der Kontrolle der
physischen Kontrolle der Krim durch
Russland aber nicht die jure also keine
rechtsanerkennung und dieser Status soll
15 Jahre lang halten bevor dann eine
endgültige Lösung angestrebt wird äh und
wie gesagt die Ukraine würde nicht der
NATO beitreten das ist Seer der Urängste
Russlands dass man als nuklearbündnis
mit amerikanischer Führung den NATO den
russischen Grenzen nicht zu nahe kommt
weil man dann ja mit Kurzstrecken Waffen
das strategische Gleichgewicht
unterminieren könnte das ist so eine Art
kuboment aus Sicht Moskaus ob man das
teilt oder nicht ist hier zweitrangig
Rüstungskontrolle Abkommen gehen immer
davon aus dass man nicht unbedingt die
Perzeptionen teilen muss aber dass man
zumindest Lösungen sucht für diese
Perzeption
das wäre dann auch möglich gewesen Kiev
hatte zumindest die
Verhandlungsdelegation hat das vorläufig
gutiert es scheint auch in Moskau gut
angekommen zu sein und die Verhandlungen
wurden dennoch im Mai abgebrochen äh
nachdem klar war dass die Ukraine
möglicherweise auch militärisch
durch die Unterstützung des Westens äh
Erfolge erzielen kann das hat sich
vielleicht in der Nachsicht jetzt als
ein Fehler herausgestellt
äh es gibt andere äh historische
Beispiele wo man also Prinzipien Fragen
durch Kompromisse gelöst hat da war ja
auch Europa und und die USA beteiligt äh
vielleicht ist das ein Weg zurück
ob das heute noch möglich ist nachdem
Moskau so viele weitere Gebiete
annektiert hat mag man bezweifeln aber
auch für Moskau wachsen die Bäume nicht
in den Himmel und man wird sich bedenken
müssen wie man aus diesem Schlamassel
herauskommt der Russland ja auch in der
Welt ich sag mal nicht isoliert hat aber
doch zumindest die Reputation Russlands
erheblich
beschädigt ja und ich bin mir sicher wir
werden zu diesem Thema bestimmt noch mal
sprechen hier bei ZDF heute live Herr
Richter vielen Dank dass Sie meine
Fragen und die Fragen der Community
beantwortet haben und ich wünsche ihn
noch einen schönen Abend ser gerne Frau
Reichel alles Gute auch guten
Abend ja und auch euch danke ich für
eure Fragen und eure Kommentare schön
dass ihr so aktiv dabei wart und wir
sehen uns das nächste mal bei ZF he live
wenn ihr mögt schönen Abend und bis
bald